bonjour bonjour où il va très bien en ce
nouveau jogging très en beauté savait
pas de séducteur
alors je suis pas séducteur je suis
séduisant c'est très différent
vous l'avez reçu l'avis fans souris fait
jamais de pauses vous même pour déjeuner
voilà des fans ce prix j'ai essayé c'est
quand même très compliqué vous savez on
se connaît non malheureusement non je
vous ai dit avec les livres d'éditeurs
belle part moi je suis un grand fan de
son travail
j'ai l'impression vous aussi les oui oui
c'est vrai julien enchanté ont chanté je
dis moi c'est ange anges
bien sûr aimons-nous ses gardiens vous
savez que bastia une conférence 4 0 mais
gabriel aussi quitté pas mal les
rencontres du zen je connais pas je vous
connaissais pas il faut bien un talent
fantastique
j'adore j'y vais tous les ans c'est un
petit peu seulement
alberto a oui ah oui